el coronavirus se expande vorazmente en
europa este jueves el gobierno de
francia amplió un 'toque de queda' con
un total de 54 regiones sujetas a la
medida y más de 46 millones de
ciudadanos confinados de 9 de la noche a
6 de la mañana
y yo les creamos digamos las cosas
claramente la situación es grave es
grave en europa y es grave en francia la
circulación del virus tuvo hoy un nivel
extremadamente elevado él ve entretanto
varias naciones reportaron más cifras de
nuevos casos sin precedentes es el caso
de alemania que registró más de 10.000
nuevos contagios en las últimas 24 horas
la noticia llega cuando el propio
ministro de salud la cara de la lucha
contra el virus en el país diera
positivo
berlín publicó advertencias de viajes a
varios lugares populares para esquiar e
impuso una cuarentena de 10 días para
aquellos que regresen al país al
contrario en españa país que reportó un
millón de casos este miércoles no hubo
un consenso político para imponer nuevas
medidas las cuales autónomas han ido
manifestando su opinión al respecto y no
hay un consenso propicio que a ningún
consenso todavía amplio al respecto y
por tanto no seguir trabajando en
futuros consejos interterritoriales con
más de 7 millones de contagios por el
patógeno el 'viejo continente'
representa el 18.5
de los casos a nivel mundial